herzlich willkommen zu unserem
jahresrückblick heute schauen wir
gemeinsam mit ihnen zurück auf unser
sternstunden jahr und auf die themen die
2018 bremsen und natürlich wagen ja auch
einen blick in die zukunft für einmal
bleiben wir drei moderatoren unter uns
ich freue mich auf das gespräch mit euch
denn gäste hatten wir ja viele und vor
allem auch dieses jahr bei uns
wunderbare sie sind ein wahrer
romantiker
ich hatte noch nie ein interviewer der
so romantisch war die leute leiten
keineswegs unter den menschenmassen
denn der globus besteht aus kleinen
einzelteilen
dazu gehören die bienen sie sind die
kleinsten und wir hängen alle
voneinander ab wenn wir uns also auf ein
kissen oder einen stuhl setzen um zu
meditieren
tun wir das nicht nur für uns selbst
viel mehr beruhigen wir unseren geist
und öffnen unser herz mehr zum nutzen
unserer mitmenschen als wir uns selber
meine ganze existenz passiert aber in
einem einer fahrrad panne die mein vater
hatte und deshalb hat er nie seine
ferien umgestellt und hat er meine
mutter kennengelernt
die menschen sind durchschnittlich
glücklicher geworden
nicht in jedem land in der schweiz sind
die menschen in den letzten 20 jahren
nicht wirklich glücklicher geworden
andererseits gibt es hier wenig luft
nach oben
wisst ihr wo so glücklich wie überhaupt
menschen möglich ist aber ich glaube es
gibt mittel gegen in fanatismus zum
beispiel der sinn für humor
ich habe noch nie einen fanatiker
gesehen der sinn für humor gehabt hätte
oder einen menschen mit sinn für humor
der fanatiker geworden werden einerseits
ist es natürlich immer richtig sich zu
fragen habe ich vielleicht unrechten
haben die anderen recht aber
andererseits darf man auch über diese
grundsätzlichen bereitschaft zu zweifeln
nicht bereit seien grundsätze allzu sehr
in frage zu stellen an die man einfach
glaubt und die selbstverständlich sein
müssen also diese emotionale prozess des
trauerns ist ein prozess der sehr weh
tut und was wehtut ist lebendig auf die
frage gibt es bewusster robert
antwort seit jahren klar ich bin einer
vision
wir sind roboter die roboter entstammen
die roboter entstammen der neid macht
wirklich diese glückseligkeit dieses
gefühl von glück zunichte und besser
haben müssen wir diese toxische
emotionen in den griff bekommen also
marx hat den kapitalismus ja von anfang
an im grunde ist ein globales
unternehmen verstanden oder als eines
das letztendlich nur global sein können
wird und das geht glaube ich für die
digitalisierung auch ja dieser
zusammenschnitt von klugen und auch sehr
optimistischen menschen zeigen uns dass
2008 ein reiches java es war auch ein
erinnerungsjahr der großen revolution
der idee der revolution karl marx der
revolutionäre vordenker der moderne
verhalte 200 jahre geburtstag und es gab
das jahr 1968 als das jahr der
mythischen revolutionen der die
lebenswelt sich neu erfand habt ihr noch
erinnerungen an 1968 von euren eltern
dass die da gemacht habe war ich bin 83
geboren
mein vater hat irgendwie noch platten zu
hause gehabt von grateful dead und
natürlich von stones und beatles und so
ich kenne das aus musik so als
kulturphänomen aber nicht so ein
politischer mensch aber ich kenne es
voran und von meinem vater her ich gar
nicht also ich hab das meine eltern auch
immer mal wieder gefragt was eigentlich
19 68 für sie bedeutet hat aber ich
glaube das hat sie jetzt nicht umgehauen
irgendwie muss es ja in dieser zeit eine
eine unzufriedenheit mit der
gesamtsituation gegeben haben eine art
energie die man heute auch manchmal zu
spüren meint ich frage mich manchmal
wenn man nicht fragen würde sehne ich
mich nach einer revolution was ich dann
überhaupt antworten würde habt ihr
darauf eine antwort
naja ich finde immer interessant wenn
man sich nochmal genau überlegt was
eigentlich max idee war mit der
revolution er hat ja betont dass man die
welt vom kopf auf die füße stellen muss
und die idee war ja eigentlich nicht
ideen werden die revolution voran
bringen sondern die konkreten
politischen unruhen und natürlich auch
die technologische erneuerungen und
insofern sehe ich mich manchmal nach
einer revolution das ich denke so dieser
politische gestaltungswille das gefühl
man kann etwas verändern dass ich schon
etwas was mich eigentlich begeistert und
so diese politikverdrossenheit macht mir
mal ein bisschen sorgen also eine art
revolution des gemeinsinns dass man
versteht dass man überhaupt etwas ändern
könnte wenn man wollte beispielsweise ja
dass man wieder die kontrolle zurück
gewinnt was politisch ich träume
irgendwie von einer inneren revolution
von einer bewusstseins revolution könnte
also ich habe immer das gefühl wir leben
irgendwie falsch
wir leben nicht so wie man leben sollte
jetzt nicht im ethischen sinn sondern
eher so existenz philosophisch also ich
war letztens eine beerdigung von der
bekannten kam nach hause und danach
fühlte sich aber so leicht an
und irgendwie das unwichtige war
wirklich unwichtig und das wichtige war
wichtig und dann am nächsten tag lege
ich mich wieder auf über irgendwelche
mails und so und man fällt wieder zurück
und eigentlich müsste man irgendwie eine
übung erfinden oder übungen um dieses
bewusstsein aufrechtzuerhalten dass wir
sterblich sind dass wir irgendwie in
einen raum zeitlich unendlichen kosmos
leben und so aber das wirst du das als
revolution bezeichnen das wäre für mich
eher eine evolution ich glaube das alles
ist doch in uns angelegt und ist eine
selbst arbeit ich verstehe schon was er
mal war das geht manchmal erfahrung und
man sieht jetzt sehe ich die welt anders
klarer und fast nur für ein oder für
zwei tage und dann geht man hier den
alltag zurück und die normale
wahrnehmung verselbstständigt sich
insofern manchmal gibt's zur öffnung
sagen sie begräbnisse geburten schwere
nachrichten sind st jetzt sehe ich die
welt eigentlich richtiger und dann
könnte man sagen eine art revolution des
alltäglichen kann von da aus ansetzen
ich glaube ihr leben verbringen so einer
blase drehen und sehen nicht was wir
eigentlich sind nämlich sterbliche
menschliche wesen die total unwichtig
sind auf der kosten eines planeten
irgendwo am rande einer galaxie und
nehmen uns die ganze zeit so total
wichtigen und das den leuten vor augen
zu führen oder auch das zukünftige
generationen kommen werden einfach diese
distanz man diese distanz zu gehen und
uns von außen zu betrachten wo wir jetzt
gerade sitzen was wir hier eigentlich
tun und das war ja auch etwas was wir
seit 68 ein motiv war dass man dinge in
den blick nimmt die wirklich wichtig
sind im leben zu sich kommt achtsamer
wird
auch sich stärker politisiert wir hatten
ein gast in der sendung den historiker
und kulturwissenschaftler philipp felsch
und die hat uns auch gezeigt dass
philosophen manchmal ganz andere
wirkungen haben als sie haben wollen
also 68 ist zunächst mal wirklich eine
kulturrevolution und das wort
fundamental liberalisierung trifft es
gut insofern sind auch die revolten die
sich in den siebziger und achtziger und
bis in die gegenwart angeschlossen haben
würde ich sagen vielfach durch diese
initialzündung 68 bedingt also man hat
über die französische revolution gesagt
die revolution frisst ihre kinder
umgekehrt kann man auch sagen die
revolution kann auch ihre leithammel
unter sich begraben stichwort
frauenbewegung die 68er selbst waren
glaube ich schon sehr patriarchal noch
kann man in den kommunen sehen da haben
die männer den ton angegeben
aber es dauerte ein paar jahre und dann
hat sich eben aus dieser bewegung heraus
auch eine frauenbewegung formiert und
die ganze ökologiebewegung dass die
anderen immer wichtiger wurde die
starter zusammen haben ja das sind wenn
man das theoretisch beschreiben will bei
marx interesse so genannte neben
widersprüche der geschlechterkampf oder
eben auch solche ökologischen fragen in
den 70er jahren rücken sie dann auf
einmal ins zentrum des augenmerks
stichwort ölkrise zugleich bröckelt aber
auch eben der glaube in diese
marxistischen konzeption des
klassenkampf und das sind dann ebenso
ich habe es vor der spaltprodukte
genannt von 68 genauso wie die raf ist
auch die ökologiebewegung der feminismus
in den 70er jahren das sind alles wenn
man so wurden die kinder dieser revolte
der nachkriegszeit
spaltprodukte da kann man sagen ökologie
das ist heute immer noch so der fall
feminismus vielleicht sogar
geschlechterkampf 2018 war immer noch
das große jahr von nico diese bewegung
ging weiter würdest du das als eine
revolutionäre bewegung bezeichnet ich
finde es total schwierig zu sagen weil
man noch nicht weiß was die auswirkungen
sein werden ich glaube viele bewegungen
kann man erst im nachhinein beurteilen
ob sie revolutionär waren oder nicht
aber was mir wichtig scheint und ich
glaube da hat die daniel binswanger ein
schweizer journalist ganz früh schon den
richtigen riecher
der feminismus scheint mir die bewegung
zu sein die am ehesten revolutionäre
sprengkraft entfalten kann und dass
deswegen weil es ja eigentlich eine
identität politische bewegung ist die
leute abholt in dem was sie auch sind
gleichzeitig ist sie eben eine
minderheiten bewegung die die mehrheit
ist und das ist das verrückte am
feminismus und das hat man ja
wahrscheinlich schon nach der wahl von
donald trump gesehen aber ich denke wenn
man an das alltägliche denkt gerade auch
für männer
nach diesem itu bewegung oft so dass man
gespräch mit frauen führte die haben
dann dinge erzählten die sie sonst nicht
erzielt hätten und man erstmal ein
bewusstsein klare dafür entwickelte
welche dinge da im stillen passieren es
gab viele gespräche die ich sonst nicht
gegeben hätte in diesem jahr das kann
sehr gut bestätigen hat unglaublich
viele gespräche geführt abends beim
essen beim glas rotwein zu diesem thema
und ich glaube es hat eine enorme
sensibilisierung stattgefunden für diese
in sexismus im alltag
ich habe kürzlich diesen französischen
film gesehen kein mann für leichte
stunden da gibt es zu wiederholen
wechsel also ein
die rollenbilder stereotype werden
vertauscht also männer werden dann so
behandelt wie frauen gehandelt werden
und umgekehrt einfach durch das man sich
dann wie eine woche so aussieht mit
allen feinheiten und details und das
wenn man keine frau ist erlebt man das
ja nicht immer das war für mich wichtig
einfach mal diese perspektive
einzunehmen für zwei stunden und so
sehen war und so viele dinge ist laufen
anders und irgendwie es gibt es ist ja
diese unzufriedenheit wenn man sagt sagt
1968 auch 1918 19 war ja auch ein großes
revolutionsjahr das jubiläum feierte
heute
jetzt wo wir sprechen gibt es die gelb
westen in frankreich es gibt in ungarn
wieder menschen die auf die straße gehen
es scheint ja auch gerade in unserer
zeit wieder sich ein revolutionäres
potenzial zu verdichten und zur stimme
zu finden
was ich interessant finde an diesem geld
westen ist das ist ja einige philosophen
oder soziologen gibt intellektuelle die
sich jetzt solidarisieren und was immer
man von dieser bewegung halten mag die
die er über beispielsweise war es ja
darauf hin dass er sagt was eigentlich
auch ein französisches so zusätzlich ja
genau die rückkehr nach st das ist das
richtige buch von die die erregung der
weiß daraufhin gesellschaft aus urteil
so heißt ja auch eines seiner bücher
gesellschaft ist heute immer noch ein
urteil damit meint der ja wir haben es
nicht geschafft politik ökonomische
verhältnisse zu schaffen die die leute
wirklich aus ihrer herkunft raus hilfen
und ich glaube das sieht man in
frankreich einfach ganz ganz groß das
sieht man aber auch in der schweiz auch
in deutschland wobei ist echt
interessantes bei diesem geld müssen
dass das der menschen sind die ihre
herkunft gerade nicht verlassen wollen
sondern am ort in der provinz bleiben
wollen um ihre lebens rechte als provinz
rechte kämpfen und das ist ja
interessant dass der fast ein mobilitäts
revolution
sie wollen sich in ihren eigenen
gebieten frei und auch günstig weiter
bewegen können ich finde es eine ganz
ganz interessante mischung zwischen
menschen die einerseits mobil sein
wollen und andererseits darauf beharren
dass ihre lebensform in der provinz auch
anerkannt wird ja genau darum geht es
doch immer so wenn man sozusagen die
gesellschaftlichen verhältnisse
kritisiert geht ja nicht darum dass man
entwurzelt werden möchte sondern davon
anerkannt sein möchte aus die person die
aus dieser gesellschaft kommt aber sowas
wie chancengleichheit ich glaube dass
diesen frankreich wirklich ein großes
problem was bricht jetzt so extrem auf
zumal im makro mit seiner mit seiner oma
es bewegung anderes versprochen hat und
jetzt gleichzeitig aus einer vom ist
habe ich schon wahrgenommen hier eine
weitere revolution die von ihren kindern
gefressen wird warum man schwitzt eine
neue bewegung die jetzt diese ganze
makro agenda in frage gestellt
das mit den dass die revolution die
eigenen kinder frisst ist also die
andere digitale große revolution im
gange ist ist das digitale die digitale
revolution und darüber haben wir dieses
jahr auch oft gesprochen und die frist
nicht ihre kinder primär sondern unsere
daten die großen konzerne wie google
facebook einmal sagen und so weiter
apple sammeln ungeheuer viel daten über
uns und das ohne ungeheure macht damit
verbunden mit diesem wissen auch wie
geht es dir denn persönlich damit um mit
dieser transparenz dass man so viele und
so große spuren hinterlässt im netz also
bei mir kann ich zb beobachten das ist
ja diese neue gesetzgebung gehabt dass
man anklicken muss dass man die cookies
akzeptiert das wird jetzt bei jeder
webseite automatisch getan
am anfang habe ich das immer gedacht ich
schaue mir das an überlegt das
mittlerweile bin ich auch automatisiert
und sage immer ja wir doch das machen ja
durch das machen ich bin selbst
schockiert wie wenig das bewusstsein und
das wissen dass ich von diesen daten
sammele aktivitäten habe auf meiner
praxis im netz rück wirkt warum in der
sehr bequem sehr dumm und auch sehr
einfach es geht mir genau gleich und
gleichzeitig ist es lege ich etwas was
mich auch beunruhigt
ich glaube die allermeisten teilen das
ja dass man sagt dann weiß um diese
daten sammele reimann weißen die
schwierigkeiten die damit verbunden sind
und die gefahren die da vielleicht
lauern und trotzdem tut man relativ
wenig es gibt schon dinge die ich
klarerweise nicht tun würde zum beispiel
die ordnungsdienste aktivieren auf
meinem smartphone das würde ich wirklich
nicht tun
ich mag es nicht wenn ich den einfachen
habe irgendjemand meist aber wir machen
uns glaube ich tatsächlich auch nicht zu
wenig gedanken
aber es sind ja auch ungeheure vorteile
damit verbunden also stichwort big data
empfehlungssystem und weiter ich war
vorgestern auf spotify und habe da
irgendwie antic bekommen und neun
künstler musiker entdeckt der einfach
total genial ist und genau das macht was
ich so schätze die musik die ich liebe
denn hätte ich sonst nicht entdeckt zu
mein spiel dass diese was oft dass
gefahr bezeichnet wenn er richtig
maschinen kennen uns besser als wir uns
selbst für eine tolle sache aber ich
verstehe genau auf den 1 aber früher
sehen jedoch ins cd oder oder
langspielplatten geschäft gegangen und
da habe ich doch immer geguckt was noch
im regal steht ich wusste genau wo ich
suchen müssen wo vielleicht
die cds ich habe sehr viele cds gibt
eigentlich ein ganzes geld aus studentin
habe ich in cds investiert nicht in
büchern sehr viel sehr viel cds gekauft
tatsächlich und da war doch auch dauernd
das gefühl man entdeckt sachen wenn man
dieses geschäft gehen der das hat der
virtuelle shops waren ich habe sich das
so sehr weil ich glaube schon dass es
der neueröffnung gibt und dass der raum
das angebot das natürlich unendlich viel
größer und breiter ist aber wenn ich an
diese entwurzelung denke da würde ich
auch sagen wir haben noch nicht richtig
gespürt wie wir entwurzelt werden können
durch die daten die bei uns verfügbar
sind ich glaube unser verhalten mein
verhalten würde sich ändern wenn ich
lebens wirklich spüren würde was jemand
mit den daten über mich wirklich tut und
je weiter das negative mein leben
angreift im moment sind das positive
eingriffe wenn es eine andere politische
konstellation gebe könnten die sehr
negativ werden und dann glaube ich wird
sich das verhalten auch ganz stark
ändern ja jetzt wird es primär für
kommerzielle zwecke verwendet
ich meine du hattest diesen wundervollen
stammtisch philosophischen stammtisch
moderiert mit richard david precht kommt
der jetta jetta und harald welzer und da
haben wir haben dir nicht nur über die
negativen sondern eben auch über die
positiven seiten der digitalisierung
gesprochen und vor allem über einen
punkt der sehr radikal ist nämlich dass
diese künstliche intelligenz und die
maschinen unser verständnis von arbeit
grundlegend verändern werden wenn ich
überlege wie die bauern in der schweiz
im 18 jahrhundert auf den feldern
gearbeitet haben ich war die schweiz war
das armenhaus europas
ja in den bergen wo es heute schöne ist
daran hier sozusagen um fruchtbarsten
wiesen
da konnte man kein getreide anbauen und
so weiter und wenn man dann guckt wenn
man sich die ganze entwicklung ankommt
heute geht es den schweizer bauern
großartig und sie arbeiten viel weniger
als sie gearbeitet haben haben sie sich
tod gearbeitet da waren 47 tod hatten
keine zähne mehr im mund waren tot ist
eine tolle entwicklung und wenn ich das
stück für stück weiter durchgehe
fabrikarbeit wie das aussah im 19
jahrhundert in england in deutschland
und so weiter dann ist das ganze eine
unglaublich positive entwicklung und wir
müssen nun die nächsten sprung in der
positiven entwicklung machen und er
besteht eben darin dass wir jetzt
anfangen die langweilige routine jobs zu
schreddern das ist doch großartig die
stimme ihn recht vollkommen zu das ist
natürlich das reicht der freiheit in
greifbare nähe
wenn es keine arbeit mehr gibt und das
geht ja sehr weit
es könnte nämlich dann zum beispiel auch
zur folge haben dass die ja wirklich
eben mit der arbeiterbewegung
paradoxerweise in die welt gekommene
hoch bewertung und entfremdete arbeit
mal wieder wegkommt es ist doch nicht
der sinn weshalb wir alle auf die welt
gekommen sind ja 40 jahre lang irgendwie
dasselbe zu tun
ja ich werde jetzt ein sozialdemokrat
hier am tisch sitzen würde würde sagen
aber sehr wohl ist es der sinn und das
wollen wir nie wieder aufgeben
wir wollen dummes zeug machen ganzes
leben und das nennen wir dann sinn des
lebens und wertvoller existent ja keine
chance arbeit mehr wird es so weit
kommen
ich glaube dass es ganz interessant vor
dem hintergrund von marx zu sehen dass
die kern frage war wer die
produktionsmittel besitzt für marx aber
eigentlich die kernfrage wie gut ist die
arbeit die die menschen tun und wie
sinnvoll es gab ja sozialistische
experiment nur umstellung wäre die
produktionsmittel besaß aber die arbeit
war qualitativ noch schlechter noch
monotoner noch schlimmer für die
menschen das heißt dieser schritt in die
digitalisierung kann wirklich der
schritt sein in dem man auch das
magische denken überwindet dass es nicht
darum geht wer die produktionsmittel
besitzt sondern welche arbeit wir
überhaupt tun wie genussvoll die ist
warum da also darum geht es doch auch um
die frage der die produktion für mich
dass ich eine extrem relevante frage und
war könnte die validierung jahr
tatsächlich eine große chance
moment werden sie monopolisiert durch
digitalisierung ja das ist absolut
richtig wobei das ist richtig aber die
ganze sharing economy möchte natürlich
gerne in eine andere richtung gehen
diesem moment noch sehr viel kleiner als
man es erwartet hat aber wenn man also
3d drucker denkt dass die leute wirklich
selber zu fusionen werden also
produzieren konsumieren gleichzeitig und
und eben neue formen von von
unternehmensführung hergestellt werden
dann würde sich das tatsächlich
verändern sich das und das könnte eine
chance sein aber glaubt ihr dass das
kommt also in dieser ausgeprägt hat das
ist diesen rat kaum waren also die die
these die wir da ja diskutiert haben ist
ja diejenige dass das heißt ein zweiter
die hälfte aller jobs werden war nicht
da die wir jetzt gar nicht mehr geben
und ob das so sein wird oder nicht
aber das ist wirklich unklar es gibt
sehr viele die das behaupten es gibt
aber auch viele die mittlerweile wieder
zurückgekrebst sind und wenn wir in der
geschichte schauen dann hat man einfach
gesehen 1950 zb gab es diese panik schon
die maschine wird übernehmen der mensch
wird keine arbeit mehr haben was folgte
fast zwei jahrzehnte vollbeschäftigung
also ich möchte nicht sagen dass das
dann so rauskommen wird ich glaube
tatsächlich wir müssen diese diese
problemstellung ernst nehmen aber ich
glaube auch nicht dass ihr all diesen
zahlen trauen sollten aber es ist ja
auch interessant wurde gesagt von von
einer welt sei hier das reich der
freiheit beginnt die leute können machen
was sie wollen
diese entlastung von arbeit bringt uns
glaube ich gar nichts zivilisatorisch
wenn wir dann die falschen dinge tun
wenn jemand der von arbeit entlastet es
dafür zehn stunden playstation spielt
dann ist das nicht das reich der
freiheit von dem ich träume das heißt
die anwohner nicht würdig eben sagen da
muss man schon auch normativ sagen es
gibt dann dinge im reich der freiheit
die für dieselbe ist entwicklung und für
den sinn im leben wichtiger sind und
jetzt droht mit dieser digitalisierung
eine ausbau des freizeitangebots das
meiner ansicht nach letztlich keine
freiheit ist sondern eine form von
dumpfen zeitvertreib
wir könnten aber auch anders denken wir
könnten wir auch in eine richtung denken
wo wir sagen das was umkehr arbeit
geleistet wird also die ganzen
pflegeleistungen betreuung von kindern
vielleicht auch betreuung von tieren das
wird dann endlich aus arbeit anerkannt
oder aus freizeit das ist ja erst einmal
gar nicht der punkt sondern auch eine
sinnstiftende und wichtige eminent
wichtige tätigkeit die im moment ja
wirklich so ein bisschen nach
unterbewertet barbara ist interessant
dass die größte hoffnung mit dieser
digitalisierung und robotik die ist dass
die pflege und die teerarbeiten uns
abgenommen werden wollen also man denkt
ja in der altenpflege zum beispiel der
träume alle davon dass das in gewisser
weise irgendwann auch maschinen tun
können japan ist das ein großes projekt
gerade die arbeiten die
zwischenmenschlich sinnvoll sind die
sollen dann auch noch maschinell
entlastet da bin ich aber da bin ich mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht so sicher sehr sehr
viele pflegeroboter sind dazu da
diejenigen arbeiten zu machen wie zb
körperlich sehr anstrengend sind also
schwere menschen zu drehen zu heben
möglicherweise ist es für gewisse leute
auch eine entlastung gibt ältere
menschen oder menschen die chronisch
krank sind die sagen es ist das
erleichtern wenn sie
sollte beispielsweise aufs töpfchen
bringt und nicht eine person aber die
ganze zwischenmenschliche arbeit und das
arbeit nehmen will oder nicht
gerade die beziehung das pflegen von
beziehungen dass ich so wichtig für uns
wenn wir dafür mehr zeit haben werden
ist das doch ein fortschritt und da wird
ja auch gesagt diese zwei ligen aus
einerseits dieses der mensch aus
beziehungs wesen das kann die künstliche
intelligenz irgendwie nicht einholen
aber auch das kreative wird oft gesagt
wie zuversichtlich seid ihr da wir das
irgendwann maschinen geben die super
intelligent sind die klüger sind oder so
könne jeder mensch ja ich glaube aber
dass ich dann unser begriff und
kreativität geändert haben wird ich weiß
nicht ob das den punkt gibt an dem ich
das nicht mehr unterscheiden können in
der literatur in der musik in der
kompositionslehre brüssel gibt es ja
schon maschinen die dinge komponieren
die ganze ununterscheidbar sind aber das
schöne aktivität kreativität im
menschlichen bereich das ergebnis dass
der prozess des schaffens selber und
diesen genuss kreativ zu sein wenn wir
uns den auch noch abnehmen lassen dann
haben wir uns selbst nicht verstanden
durch ok aber die produkte können
genauso kreativ wirken und irgendwie
zustande kommen wie es scheint dass sie
lacht das scheint absehbar das glaube
ich schon ja aber das ist nicht
vielleicht auch druck von und siehst du
diese musik dann hören und diese
kunstwerke
das glaube ich schon dass die
ästhetische erfahrung bewirkt warum dich
ja aber das ist zum beispiel auch etwas
extrem interessantes finde ich würde man
das hören wollen und dass viele leute
doch den eindruck haben es nach doch ein
unterschied ob ich im konzert sie und
weiß was hat johann sebastian bach
komponiert oder das hat ein
entsprechendes dazu kommen komponiert
und wir wissen ja es gibt programme den
blind doppelblindstudien da wurde
gezeigt dass die leute das nicht
unterscheiden können natürlich und
deswegen stelle ich mir schon die frage
was ist eigentlich wirklich noch der
unterschied und viele leute sagen doch
es ist ein unterschied schon nur das
wissen dass das die echte karte sieg ist
macht für mich den unterschied ich kann
das ehrlich gesagt nicht nachvollziehen
aber fangen wir manchmal könnte es ja
auch entlassungs sein zu sagen ich mag
den song aber ich mag die person
dahinter nicht muss mir dann immer das
gesicht dazu vorstellen
da wäre mir als wichtiger manchmal so
sagen es werden roboter dann kann ich
die musik noch mehr genießen
das nehme ich mich abmelde doch
verstanden werden diese welt schmerzt
eines beethoven wirst du irgendwie dich
in dem wiedererkennen und sagen wenn du
weißt dass hatten die maschine gemacht
kann den roboter keine weltschmerz einer
sich zumindest nicht ich glaube auch
hier glaubt zb das robot seine emotionen
haben werden ja das würde davon abhängen
ob diese roboter in irgendeiner form ein
organisches material angeschlossen
werden können es gibt ja diese
zwischenform das ist ja denkbar dass es
da mischform gibt aber ohne organische
substrate glaube ich nicht dass wir von
emotionen reden sollte warum ist das so
wichtig ist die materielle basis die
neuronen und organischen weil es sich
wie ein philosophie thomas [ __ ] gesagt
anfühlt eine erdbeere zu essen ein
schmerz zu haben es gibt da ein qual wie
die philosophen sagen und es ist nicht
leicht zu sehen wie dieses qual ja
dieses gefühl wie es sich anfühlt wie
das maschinelle überhaupt entstehen soll
ich glaube auch dass so dass das niemand
bisher erklären kann ist noch nicht klar
wie es bei uns im gehirn wenn ich jetzt
tue ich mich jetzt hier zwickl haben ist
ein relativ klare geschichte die ich
erzählen kann diesen zwecken ins gehirn
geht und dann kann man etwas auf jeden
fall beobachten von dem mir sagen können
sie können nicht genau sagen wie sind
gehirn den schmerz auslöst und wir
können uns keine geschichte erzählen wie
ein maschinelles system zu dieser
erfahrung kommen so aber wir können
irgendwann wenn wir das hier nachbauen
können ganz genau nachvollziehen was
passiert wenn ich dich zwicke da oben in
deinem kopf und dasselbe in einer
künstlichen intelligenz auslösen
natürlich weiß nicht ob khwaja mäßig
dieser roboter das auch so empfindet ja
aber du kannst es auch nicht
ausschließen ich weiß es ja bei dir
letztlich auch nicht kann ich nicht
reingucken ja was schon immer mal
gestehen dass ich fragte auch übrigens
dank der dan ettinger cent genau denn
vielleicht zum schluss noch von dieser
digitalisierung diese diese smartphones
und all diese geräte
das ist ja auch ein stressfaktor wie
erlebt ihr das wie geht er damit um
also ich bin würde mich als manifest
abhängig bezeichnen und leide auch
darunter
aber ich habe für mich auszeiten ich
habe also digital die talks wie man das
sagt oder eine abstinenz und ich gehe
dann immer ein ort an dem es kein netz
gibt und bleibt dafür drei vier wochen
und versucht dann auch wirklich ganz aus
einem raus zu sein und das wirkt extrem
heilsamen kommt mir zumindest so vor die
gitarristen möchte ich unbedingt noch
vertiefen ist mir wirklich echt gerne
verstehen
die meisten leute sagen von sich
mittlerweile ich bin ganz klar abhängig
und lachen noch dazu wie du es eben auch
genau was aber sind eigentlich für eine
gesellschaft wo wir einfach alle sagen
ja wir sind davon abhängig was ist das
für zu schauen das ist das ein
gesellschaftsbild
also ich geb dir dinge an die man
abhängig unter denen man erstmal nicht
leidet man sagt einfach das ist ein
muster das muss ich wieder holen zum
beispiel rituale haben gewisse dinge
nicht lassen können
manche leute sind abhängig vom
fußballspielen vielleicht müssen das
fünfmal die woche tun um sich wohl zu
fühlen könnten nicht ohne das leben ist
vielleicht eine bessere beschreibung
ich habe noch nichts gefühl dass ich
sehr stark täglich darunter leide
aber ich merke dass sich in den guten
und zeigt muster verfallen
die unbewusst sind und das ist dann
einfach den computer einschalte und
etwas tue was ich gar nicht bedenken und
das ist der punkt wo man sich ein
bisschen unheimlich wird wenn man sich
da nicht selbst als freies lesen
empfindet ist eine erfahrung von
kontrollverlust ländlich dann wenn man
hat wenn es zu diesen dingen greift und
wenn man einfach den computer anschauen
fernseher und so weiter man macht das
nicht bewusst und ich denke es geht
wirklich darum wieder die seiten bewusst
und kontrolliert zu machen und wenn ich
nach hause komme dann muss ich irgendwie
erst mal 20 minuten halbe stunde ruhe
haben und nichts haben sofern die kleine
tochter nicht da ist um überhaupt aus
diesem modus raus zu kommen weil sonst
ist man einfach drin und man verliert
die kontrolle und dass sie am anfang
gesagt dass für dich eigentlich eine
wirkliche revolution von nöten sein wenn
es darum geht die sachen wieder ins
verhältnis zu setzen und wirklich in
kontakt zu kommen mit den dingen die
wirklich zählen und das ist zb etwas was
nicht extrem beschäftigt das neue jahr
war heiß menschen hatten das ist glaube
ich im durchschnitt nach sieben minuten
aus oder ihre mails zu checken und das
was zählt findet ja selten in diesen
mails start sind wir mal ehrlich oder
auf twitter oder facebook
und diese frage das ist das was ich
meine es beschäftigt mich wenn jedoch
alle abhängig sind von einem keinen
digitalen babysitter oder ablenkt
manöver kommen die eigentlich überhaupt
noch zu dieser revolution zu diesem
moment merken aber darum ging es ähnlich
ich glaube es ist besonders schön dass
er dass man manchmal zwei stunden mit
einem menschen verbrannt und mit ihm
spricht und dann fällt einem selber auf
ich habe nicht einmal aufs smartphone
geguckt ich habe nicht einmal daran
gedacht
auf facebook los und jeder glaube ich
die nicht kenne wie du sagen das waren
die eigentlich guten gründen meines
lebens und ich glaube ich das
philosophieren und philosophielehrer
lesen auch solche stunden sendete man
die geistige gesundheit pflegt und wenn
es gut läuft vergisst man die raum und
zeit und auch das ganze internet und ich
glaube wir müssen einfach technik
entwickeln in diesen in diesem fluss
reinzukommen dass da hab ich muss voll
ist so ein großartigen job weil ich ins
studio kam man keine mails checken aber
etwas was mich schon beschäftigt bei
dieser ganzen digitalisierung ist
wirklich das tempo was immer schneller
wird und diese unfähigkeit sich eben
noch zur ruhe zu setzen und sich
konzentrieren zu können
ich habe kürzlich gelesen dass ein
drittel aller menschen wenn eine seite
länger aus zwei sekunden lebten nicht
mehr bereit sind das laden der seite
abzuwarten das heißt die seite wird
weggeklickt wenn die länge aus zwei
sekunden lebt sagt wie unwichtig diese
seite ist für diesen menschen weiß ich
nicht zeigt doch wie ungeduldig esse ich
glaube dass tatsächlich dass das wird
ein politisch vielleicht auch ein
interessanter gedanke wir sind durch
diese beschleunigungs erfahrung dieses
klicken es auch in vielen politischen
prozessen wahnsinnig ungeduldig geworden
die lebenswelt sich erfahrung dass alles
schnell hochlädt und alles funktioniert
die wird irgendwo aufs politischen
übertragen
und wenn das nicht genauso steil geht
dann macht irgendetwas falsch die
institutionen funktioniert große
unzufriedenheit also ich glaube dass die
digitalisierung in ihrem beschleunigungs
waren uns lebensweltlich unzufriedener
macht und das wird politisch in eine
gefährliche situation weil direkte
demokratie oder demokrat generell etwas
langsam ist und auch sein sollte würdest
du sagen das hat politische sprengkraft
gibt es eine kritische unwucht würde ich
sagen ja es gibt ja auch diesen begriff
des fried auf der der neue burnout ist
der genau damit zu tun hat dass nämlich
die leute immer schneller reagieren und
dadurch auch immer mehr quasi intuitiv
bauchgefühl mäßig einfach mal rum
brüllen und so ihre reaktionen finden
und gar nicht mehr in sich selbst
geiseln jetzt kann man sagen naja freak
out es vielleicht besser aus burnout
besser als wenn die leute einfach
zusammenbrechen
aber ich finde schon auch dass diese
überhitzung für die demokratie eine
große gefahr ist weil die die fähigkeit
zuzuhören
fähigkeit auszuhalten dass etwas zeit
braucht bis es entwickelt ist
kompromisse zu finden zum beispiel
braucht sehr viel zeit und diese zeit
haben wir oft nicht mehr dabei ist
interessant finde dass das was man
früher wutanfall macht nannte jetzt gibt
es den freak out der wert noch
theoretisch irgendwie überlagert die
fassung verlieren ich glaube dass das
gab es zu jeder zeit quasi aber ich
verstehe was du meinst dass dieses dass
dieses dass dieses dass die
digitalisierung das noch näher liegt das
problem ist wenn du die fassung verliert
dann ist es sehr oft so dass nicht nur
wir beide das mitkriegen sondern gleich
eine riesen community war nämlich die
meisten leute die fassung im internet
verlieren und zeigen welche haus
kommentare posten aber wir nicht nach
unglaublich viel getan gegen diese
beschleunigung gegen diese überhitzt
stichwort meditation yoga spiritualität
irgendwie sloane living und soweit es
gibt auch diese gegend trends und diesen
erinnerung stark ich würde sagen dass
letztlich achtsamkeitstraining soll
selbst sagen bücher lesen können
mittlerweile dazu also dass menschen
eine kontinuierliche erfahrung mit einem
gegenstand länger suchen das kann in der
meditation sein
ich zum beispiel schaue mir gerne bäume
an das er lange ich würde das neue e
mail ja wirken die sich im wind
hier finden sind mache ich das wirklich
stundenlang ich weiß nicht ob man das
eine meditations- nennt aber es ist
trotzdem die schöne erfahrung den geist
von etwas dauerhaft gefüllt zu sehen und
diese achtsamkeit techniken
das sind wahrscheinlich die die großen
sammlungs techniken jetzt unserer zeit
können oder sachen joghurt sein oder was
künstlich in der natur macht ja aber
sagt oder glaube viele viele auch
östliche wasser natürlich geht das per
potenziell mit jedem gegenstand weil
jeder gegenstand wenn man den lang genug
anschaut eine komplexität und schönheit
hat die es verdient sich darin zu
versenken
dieses glas auch oder deine brille oder
dieser brief das geht es glaube ich
schon
ich finde das ja alles wunderbare
technik kann man kann auch einfach sagen
andere beschäftigungen um es war ein
bisschen weniger hoch zu hängen aber
eine schwierigkeit ist ja und sie haben
hier immer wieder im sternstunden studio
diskutiert auch dieses jahr wieder dass
diese ganze menge bewegen
achtsamkeit bewegen der hype um die
meditation ja mittlerweile auch wieder
zu einem trend geworden ist entsprechend
vermarktet wird und man scheint es ja
schon ein bisschen absurd zu sein dass
gerade im silicon valley wo eigentlich
diese ganzen abstieg und so auf tempo
drehen und uns von dieser vielen zeit
wegfressen entwickelt werden von
menschen die gleichzeitig großen guru
sind in der achtsamkeit bewegung
empfindet ihr das auch so dass das was
du bist eine doppelbödigkeit und eine
doppelmoral hat ja klar letztlich macht
man das um effizienter und
leistungsfähiger zu sein man nimmt sich
auszeiten um wieder voll arbeiten zu
können ich glaube das ist natürlich die
kapitalistische logik dahinter und
deswegen empfehlen die unternehmen die
großen konzerne auch solche meint von es
achtsamkeit kurse
die machen das nicht um du auch birken
meditation eine leistungsfähige nein ich
würde nicht sagen dass es einen
leistungsgedanken also es hat auch eine
form von sammlung zu sich selbst kommen
ich glaube in diesem feld meditation und
yoga gibt es noch eine andere spannung
das ist das narzisstische yoga an dem
man sich ganz auf sich selbst
konzentriert bei sich bleiben will sich
selbst lehren will und dann gibt es ja
ursprünglich der gedanken dass das
empathie fördert ist dass man die leiden
und die nöte anderer menschen bewusster
wahrnehmen kann und ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das stark genug betont wird
dass diese technik ja eigentlich eine
empathie technik ist die auf tätige
sorge für andere menschen abzielt und so
dass gar nicht wahrgenommen oft ja das
wird oft nicht so wahrgenommen aber
diejenigen die wirklich aus der
leidvollen heißt bewegung heraus kommen
betonen dass ja sehr es gibt ja ganz
viele bücher die sich um diese empathie
mitgefühl drehen und die sache hatte ich
genau das dass sie zeigen können dass
das hier genau diese strukturen sich
verändern wenn man lange meditiert die
eben das mitgefühl sozusagen anzeigen
also ich glaube schon und auch
ursprünglichen buddhismus ist das ja
eigentlich eine wichtige komponente es
geht nicht einfach nur mein ego trip
selber zur ruhe kommen nun für mich
sorgen sondern in der selbstsorge fähig
zu werden sich um den anderen in die
welt zusammen im amerikanisch sagt man
da gibt es me time zeit für mich in der
ich mich mit sich mit sich selbst pflege
auseinandersetzen müsste man sagen so
was wie yoga ist utah das ist eine zeit
in der ich mich für andere menschen
öffnen indem ich eine gewisse form von
wahrnehmung kultivierte und das
scheint mir vollkommen überspielt zu
sein die meisten menschen würde ich
sagen dass yoga studium weil sie selbst
abspann worden weil sie für sich selbst
etwas erreichen wollen das geht nicht da
hin dass man praktisch sich um andere
menschen kümmert was eigentlich das ziel
der übung gewesen sein so richtig wissen
also manchmal denke ich auch wie
urteilen sehr schnell darüber was andere
leute im yoga studio so machen ich gehe
auch ein yogastudio aber übrigens ab ob
für mein tun es da gab es ja die
sendungen die wir in einer außen
produktion realisiert haben
und das war eine lustige erfahrung für
mich weil das land die erste sendung die
ich hab dir wo ich meinen kopf gar nicht
richtig gesehen habe ich kann man songs
nach ja gar nicht so recht was man die
übertragen wir sehen haben heute hinter
meditationszentrum wir haben so viele
räucherstäbchen angezündet mein kopf war
schlecht gesehen hab ich ja gleich
gesagt ich gibt gleich um habe dir auch
ein bisschen irre studio erfahrungen ich
will ja vielleicht du ich hatte eine
sendung mit der norwegischen
schriftsteller einmal runde
und da hatten wir für den buch
geschrieben über bienen über bienen
sterben und sehr erfolgreiches buch und
da hatten wir bienen und einen
bienenstock im studio
diese machen so ein kleines zum geräusch
das die ganze zeit in dem hintergrund
und das schöne aber das wusste ich davor
gar nicht wenn man diese bienen anfasst
die erzeugen wärme bewegungs wärme das
heißt so ein bienenstock ist immer so
warum 38 40 grad warm das unglaublich
beruhigend und schön sich von dieser
bienen wärme berühren zu lassen haben
die hand an die scheibe legt dann spürt
man wirklich die die bewegungs wärme der
vielen und das war ein ganz schönes
erlebnis aber dass das interessante
haben wir schon über die birken
gesprochen in dem ein schönes bewegung
wird natürlich über die rosinen sprechen
jetzt sind wir bei den bienen wir sind
natürlich noch die schnecke ein ich
hatte ja eine sendung das wandern mit
florian werners gehen und aber
eigentlich die schnecke der totale star
der sendung weil viele leute nachher
geschrieben haben sie hätten noch nie in
ihrem leben eine schnecke von so nah
gesehen unabhängig tatsächlich dieses
studio tierchen die laufen uns ja echt
und unseren gästen den rang ab hund und
tiere gehen immer
nicht immer aber es ist interessant ihre
den größten gedanken schlagen
ganz einfach weil sie da sind die natur
ist einfach ein riesen wunder was ich
bin unglaublich gerne in der natur und
wenn man solche sachen sieht was
überhaupt leben ist und will eben
irgendwie entsteht und wuselt und wabert
und wie irgendwie die grenze ist
zwischen toten und lebendigen und wie
viele evolution wie viele millionen
jahre in unserem körper drehen stecken
und so weit ist wenn ich so faszinierend
und das ist ja auch schön dass man denkt
eigentlich ein ideales philosophie ist
gespräch von ihm sagt man ja es soll
lebendig sein dass er genau dieses war
an der wunde vielfältige haben also ob
man durch die sprache das leben selbst
in seiner vielfalt simulieren wollte
schön jetzt ja auch immer an unserem
sternstunden tisch wenn es persönlich
wird wenn man den eindruck hat der gast
kommt selber ins denken und erzählt von
sich aus etwas was man so überhaupt
nicht erwartet hat mich ja zum beispiel
sehr berührt die ferdinand von schirach
über seine erfahrung mit der einsamkeit
gerichtet habe wo man wirklich so
gemerkt hat hier öffnet sich jemand und
teilt etwas was nicht lieblich sehr
berührt hat
mir ging es endlich mit dem soziologen
richard sennett der hat sehr offen in
der sendung wir haben in berlin
aufgezeichnet hat er erzählt über seinen
schlaganfall wir alles wieder lernen
musste zu gehen zu sprechen zu schreiben
cello zu spielen ist eigentlich ein
begnadeter musiker gewesen hatte eben
seinen jungen jahren jugendjahren eine
verletzung erlitten und der linken hand
eine operation schief gegangen hat mir
in der sendung gesagt eigentlich wenn
das nicht passiert wäre wäre heute
musiker und da ist heute einer der
größten intellektuellen das ist meine
das ist das sind wirklich diese
unvergesslichen momente wir hatten eine
sendung über das trauern mit verena kast
und willem ii und da hat man auch
gesehen dass es über gewisse dinge gar
nicht sinnvoll ist in der dritten person
zu sprechen sondern dass man von eigenen
erfahrungen aussprechen muss und gerade
die trauer ist ja so emotional belegt
und einen moment in dieser sendung hat
er sogar einen gast eine träne in den
augen weil er sich so stark darin
erinnerte das war auch ein moment der
mir sehr schön und nachschieben
wenn wir vom sprechen reden
philosophieren heißt ja sprechen
menschen entsprechend gelesen die
gesprächskultur und ein mutmaßlicher
verfall derselben ist ja auch ein riesen
thema gewesen 2018 da kann man sagen
gibt es zwei theorien
wir werden immer größer und unflätiger
miteinander oder wir werden immer
empfindlicher was würdest du sagen die
ist richtig
ich glaube ich würde sagen man kann
beides beobachten ich würde erstmal
sagen so im digitalen gibt es zwei
tendenzen einerseits lieferung des des
diskurses durch diese anonymität die
daher stattlich schreibe jemanden den
ich nicht gegenüber sitzen habe der mir
nicht aus ganzer mensch da ist mit dem
ich nichts teil das oder er hat einfach
eine andere meinung und ich weiß nur
dass über ihn nämlich dass eine andere
meinung hat und das andere ist diese
geschlossenheit von diesen babbels von
diesen filter blasen oder zumindest die
gefahr dass das besteht dass man nur
noch mit meinungen in kontakt konnte
eben zu meinem mindset passten zu dem
was ich für war hatte also
gleichgesinnte treffen sich
untereinander und dann wird das schreit
natürlich umso heftiger wenn man da mal
die gegenposition hat und der noch
anonym ist das würde ich sagen ist das
was ich feststelle im digitalen
ich bin ja um sich also ich glaube ich
das ganze sogenannte snowflakes phänomen
also auf den amerikanischen
universitätscampus dass die leute da
irgendwie nur noch auf ihre
befindlichkeit achten und so hoch
sensibel man darf überhaupt nichts mehr
sagen
ich glaube dass es dieses phänomen das
gibt's ja bestimmt da würde ja auch sehr
sehr viel darüber diskutiert aber es
scheint mir jetzt in unseren
breitengraden so nicht vorhanden zu sein
ich glaube diese ganzen events
identitäts politischen hochgekochten
verheerungen vielleicht auch die gibt es
so bei uns nicht und die haben aber auch
historische bedingtheit kulturelle
verfasstheit in den usa und dem ganzen
rest den man da
eine andere kulturelle situation
erschien ich muss ja nicht gesagt haben
mir ging es zuweilen so dass ich dachte
die politische korrektheit kriegt jetzt
zu schlechte karten
was ich dann irgendwie auch nicht mehr
richtig finde weil ich glaube an sich
ist es eine große errungenschaft gelernt
zu haben anständig miteinander zu
sprechen und erst mal rücksicht zu
nehmen auch ein öffentlichkeiten und was
genau eine zuseher übertriebene
empfindlichkeit ist ja das muss man
bereits aus diskutieren
aber da wäre ich erst mal wirklich auf
der seite derjenigen die sich
diskriminiert fühlen und würdigen
gedenkens mich nicht so viel kostet
rücksicht zu nehmen ja dann soll ich
auch ersichtlich
wir hatten ja ein gast hier auch immer
man geholt hat gesagt die stilisierung
des eigenen selbst als opfer ist ein
sehr wichtiger zug in einem gespräch
denn wenn man erst mal in der opferrolle
ist hat man potenziell er recht hat
andere rechte das heißt wenn man sich
selbst als opfer präsentiert ist das
ganze gespräch anders gelagert ich fand
das eine sehr sehr interessante
beobachtung wenn man das gefühl hat dass
es geradezu manchmal eine art opfer
wettlauf gibt dass man in diskursen
sieht dass man in dieser opfer position
ist um dann im gespräch andere dinge
vorbringen zu können und anders
vorbringen zu können
du würdest du sagen dass das existiert
das eine richtige diagnose würdest du
sagen es gibt diese
überempfindlichkeiten die verbraucher zu
müssen
ich glaube es ist wirklich ist kann ja
beides stimmen es kann sein dass opfer
neue medien finden um ihre nöte zu
artikulieren und dass man dort neue
dinge sichtbar wird und es kann auch
sein dass manche menschen gleichsam wie
trittbrettfahrer dieses phänomen
ausnutzen und sich selbst ein opfer
situation bringen imaginieren
stilisieren um dann rhetorisch besser
dazustehen
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass wir eine
gleichzeitigkeit dieser situation abend
in st gleichzeitig gibt es aber auch in
diesem so genannten opfer diskurs das
phänomen dass keine opfer sein will also
du opfer ist ja auch ein schimpfwort
geworden
also möchte ihn ja auch immer stark da
sein ich glaube so eine zwischenposition
wäre tatsächlich dass das problem der
einspielung sozusagen sich auf einer
anderen einlassen und so eine
mittelposition zu haben zu sehen es ist
schön stark sein zu dürfen anerkannt
sein zu dürfen
aber wie alle haben auch situationen wo
wir uns schwach und schlecht fühlen und
vielleicht auch diskriminiert
man muss diese sprache zum teil auch
lernen also ich hatte ja das glück ein
gespräch führen also ich konnte ein
gespräch führen mit 2 tanzen personen in
diesem jahr schon jetzt war das war
schwierig für mich weil ich erst mal
irgendwie das vokabular mir aneignen
musste geredet man den über jemanden und
welche fragen darf man nicht stehen und
sollte man nicht stellen usw
und ich habe unglaublich viel gelernt
aber es war ein schwieriger prozess
und dazu gehört doch auch das ist etwas
was nicht echt beschäftigt darüber haben
sie auch mit dieter mangold gesprochen
dass diese frage woher kommst du
eigentlich ja auch so ein bisschen in
verruf geraten ist und ich verstehe
durchaus deswegen weil man die andere
person nämlich darauf reduziert wie sie
aussieht nämlich wie einer der nicht von
hier ist und gleichzeitig finde ich es
selber schwierig überhaupt noch
interesse zu zeigen und die richtigen
fragen zu stellen wenn man gleich hat
jemand den eindruck kann man muss
aufpassen genau also auch wir haben ja
auch gesprochen mit menschen zum
beispiel den in rollstühlen sitzen nicht
zu fragen wie es denn eigentlich im
rollstuhl sondern erst zu fahren etwas
was ganz allgemein ist aber wie kann man
sich interessieren für andere menschen
ohne auf das spezifische bezug zu nehmen
das finde ich echt eine herausforderung
ganz spannend heraus es gibt ja ein
gespräch in dem man das einüben kann
nämlich das sogenannte selbstgespräch
man kann das auch denken denn man
spricht ja die ganze zeit in gewisser
weise mit sich selbst und was ist mit
diesem selbstgespräch auch philosophisch
auf sich hat das hat die philosophie war
von rede kann mit einer sendung zu
hannah arendt hier sehr sehr schön
erklärt
das muss in der freundschaft einen
gegenüber gefunden werden mit dem man
nie aufhören kann funken zu schlagen und
das ist ja dann letztlich auch das was
arendt als bild für das eigene selbst
verhältnis vorschlägt also ist man so
sagen eben wieder streit mit sich selbst
wie mit einem freund im denken weiter
kommt und nicht im denken bestätigt wird
dass dafür bräuchte man ja auch niemand
sonst es interessante idee dass man mit
sich selbst so befreundet ist sie mich
jemand anderem zielt darauf ab dass man
sich selbst die ganze zeit heraus
langweilig ja also ich glaube ich weiß
gar nicht ob widerspruch einspruch ist
vielleicht besser also man hat ja diese
vorstellung vom denken als etwas man man
man stellt sich etwas vormann
die sich was vor dem inneren auge man
denkt darüber nach und lässt dann gibt
es im gleichen zuge immer wieder die
auflösungs bewegung also alles was man
im denken tut es dass man immer wieder
merkt oh hier geht es jetzt nicht weiter
oder das spricht dagegen oder wenn ich
schon hier betrachtet sieht es doch
anders aus und ich glaube widerspruch
hat schon fast zu viel
statiker klarheit dafür dann wieder
haben sie zwei klare seiten ich habe das
gefühl dass sozusagen dieses jahr einige
denken und wieder aufrappeln noch offene
enden hat als ein klarer widerspruch in
sozusagen ein sprechendes denken aber
einen möglichst vielstimmiges
fantastischer gedanke man ist mit sich
selbst befreundet weil man selbst gegen
die eigenen meinungen einspruch erheben
kann redest du auch somit das heißt
jetzt aber falsch gesehen man ihr rufen
das kenne ich ja hoffentlich an er will
ich finde das gehört auch zum
erwachsensein dazu dass man reflektiert
und ja ich habe da nicht einfach es mit
sich selbst
die gefahr besteht natürlich dass dieser
innere kritiker dann zu laut ist und den
inneren freund überstimmt und dass man
wenn man mit sich selbst spricht nur
noch immer negativ spricht das ist die
große gefahr würde ich sagen ich wenn
ich mit mir selber spreche dann mache
ich das eigentlich früher habe ich viel
über die zukunft nachgedacht und jetzt
je älter ich werde ich bin 535 denke ich
oft in die über die vergangenheit nach
schwierigen erinnerung das sind für mich
die momente wo hingeht was entsteht wo
ich mich selbst besser kennenlernen
worüber sprichst du damit ihr selbst am
liebsten eben über die vergangenheit
würde ich sagen im moment warum hast du
das damals gemacht wie fühlt sich das an
und ich lerne mich so durch meine eigene
geschichte nochmal besser kennen weil
ich in die eigenen erinnerungen lang
ausgeblendet habe hat mich nicht
interessiert sie habe nachfolge guckt er
ist doch toll dass meine art
rekonstruktive selbstgespräch führt um
selber sich ständig zu dynamisieren und
zu fragen der mann eigentlich ist und
sein dass sie so ein bisschen wie max
frisch man erzählt sich dauernd gegen
die eine geschichte und hält das für
seine biografie
gesagt ich weiß es nicht worüber ich mit
mir sprechen ich finde für mich fast die
interessantere frage vielleicht findet
ihr dicht auf das eigenartig in welcher
sprache spricht man eigentlich mit sich
selbst
ich spreche zwei dialekte und das ist
wirklich interessant dass ich
festgestellt habe dass ich nicht immer
im gleichen dialekt mit mir sprechen
muss für die leute ja ich spreche
einerseits baseldeutsch und andererseits
diese promenadenmischung keine zürich
irgendwas das ist interessant mit meinen
kindern spreche ich ja nur baseldeutsch
mit dir spreche ich ja den anderen
dialekt und wenn ich mit mir selber
spreche dann ist es meistens meine
kindheit sprache also der partner direkt
aber manchmal gibt es dann in das andere
und das hat meistens zu tun mit
arbeitskonferenz sozusagen sicherheit
kann und wie weit die analyse ist aber
es ist ja auch interessant ist wenn man
länger an den sprachraum lebt man
irgendwann versuchen die sprache zu
wechseln und dann merkt man ruhig ich
denke jetzt in dieser anderen sprache
und was sich auch daran fasziniert ist
dass man in einer anderen sprache
wirklich ein anderer mensch ist andere
seiten der personen kommen hervor
deswegen so interessant zu sehen welche
sprache man vorüber mit sie spricht als
obmann anderen aspekt von sich frei
legen würde natürlich ganz unsinnige
dinge ich da die mannschaftsaufstellung
die taktischen meine mannschaft für
nächste für das nächste spiel denken
schon viel nachrede aber vor allem das
ist ganz ganz schlimm sehr viel mit
meinem hund das ist ja eine art
abgelenkt das selbstgespräch man spricht
eigentlich mit sich selber aber man
spricht mit dem hund und ich finde
haustiere haben diese wundervolle
eigenschaft dass sie sozusagen extra
sierte selbst sind dass man ab und zu an
sprechen kann dass schweigt aber ich
spreche mit meinem hund über viele dinge
die mich beschäftigen und dass das ist
eigentlich die form des gesprächs die
über ried langenstein weiteren gelangen
versteht gar nichts ich meinen schein
und heidecker aber versteht ein hund
überhaupt gar nicht was den satz doch
der versteht stimmungen stimmung die
sich verbalisieren und der ist oft
besser darüber unterrichtet wie es mir
geht als ich selbst also ich merke an
dem hund welcher stimmung man selbst
austreiben deswegen sind tiere wirklich
auch so so spiegel der eigenen stimmung
also
katzen und hunde sind hier sehr darauf
insbesondere hunde getrimmt er
stimmungen von anderen wesen
wahrzunehmen weil sie von ihnen abhängen
deswegen sind haustiere wirklich auch so
tolles aber wir werden ja hoffentlich
ganz sicher sogar
nächstes jahr auch eine sendung zur
philosophie des hundes haben weil es
nicht der beste freund des menschen ist
auch der klügste ein neues studio tier
auftaucht
als ich meinen hund ist sehr schlecht
erzogen ich glaube da wird die sendung
nach drei minuten sprengen
aber halt noch mal der gedanke fast eine
großen schönen gedanken für mich aus den
sternstunden mit sich selbst befreundet
sein heißt sich selbst widerspruch
leisten zu können ist eine schöne idee
von freundschaften das ist gar keine
einigkeit ist sondern ein beständiger
als ich eröffne der widerspruch
schön also ich werde anfang des nächsten
jahres im sechsten januar mit der
philosophen romy aster und mit der
publizistin und bühnenautorin laura de
weck sprechen genau über dieses thema
wie wir miteinander reden sorgen wie wir
mit andersdenkenden reden sollen zum
beispiel mit verwandten die über gott
die welt nicht die politik anders denken
also in zukunft wird das thema bleiben
und jetzt schauen wir noch in die
zukunft aber so richtig und zwar mit
bleigießen jetzt kommt der schönste teil
dieser sendung jetzt wird es magisch
jetzt kann am meisten schliff geben wenn
ich mal sagen ich hätte gesagt das ist
auch dieses ritual rituale sind ja
wichtig um ja aber das übergang nicht
wahr
warum weil man die übergangsphasen als
kritisch empfindet und man sicher etwas
festhält was man jedes jahr tun kann zb
nehme ich mal an und bedanke nicht
einfach mal wir haben wieder so viel
post kriechen das ist nur ein bruchteil
der post die wir gekriegt haben
ja die sind noch echte briefe wir
kriegen noch briefe irgendein richtige
richtung bewegen auch sehr groß
die kriegen richtige briefe und an
dieser stelle möchte ich einfach gerne
mal sagen schreiben sie uns auch wenn
sie eine idee haben für einen kauft wenn
sie sich eine spezielle person wünschen
wir setzen alles daran interessante
menschen hier ins studio zu holen wir
bedanken uns sehr für die post und die
adresse ist philosophie des treffpunkt
ch wenn sie gerne mal uns einen hinweis
geben rechten gedanken muss jetzt schon
ja nicht raus trennt man sich gar nicht
dass es brennt aber es brennt es brennt
also ist es nicht
naja man kann die zukunft haben
ich kann sagen dass die sonne morgen
wieder aufgeht also wahnsinnig schönes
zitat von einem philosophen den ich sehr
schätze führten ausweitete sagt es ist
die aufgabe der zukunft gefährlich zu
sein und das ist eine sehr schöne sicht
auf die zukunft das heißt dass wir das
nicht können das nicht etwas das wir als
insuffizienz oder nicht können
betrachten sollten dann leben wir gar
keinen sinn machen wenn wir das können
jetzt weiß ich nicht wie schnell muss
das hier rein tun die alles entscheiden
was bringt die zukunft für die
sternstunden 2009/10 in blei gegossen
ein knaller würde ich sagen das muss man
jetzt tun erstens rausnehmen diese nicht
auch ich muss erst mal dass hier noch
das brennt jetzt weiter was machst du
voran so die philosophen dann deutet
anderer du zuerst präsentiert auf der
hand das ist was gleichmäßig ist nicht
ein kristall ein blumenkohl vielleicht
ein blumenkohl
ich sehe eine flug schneckenform mit
zwei flügen und das wäre doch ein
wahnsinnig schöner ausblick für 2018
dass wir fliegend langsam
die dinge überschauen und darüber
nachdenken können die fluke passt auf
jeden projektes ist die minimale
hoffnung stärker das ist etwas anderes
was ich sehe was ein rhizom ja genauso
ich ja schon gesagt hat was wir zu tun
mit einer pflanze glaube ich auch dass
interessant ist die finde ich ja dass
man hier so einen prospekt dazu
geliefert kriegt und ich hab mich was
kaputt gelacht was ich das vorhin
gesehen habe weil langsam zum beispiel
könnten wir was würde denn da passen zb
ein gebiss nicht wirklich dasteht dann
zahnarzt aufsuchen was gibt zuvor
gefertigt
es gibt sofort oder baum das heißt wir
sind treue freunde ist nicht ausbauen
bezeichnen vielleicht eine etwas glück
haben uns ja an strich glaube es ist ein
brachen ja ja das heißt nur nicht in die
luft gehen
das drachen ist ja auch das chinesische
magische tier vielleicht merken wir auch
dass drei fluss von europa weg geht das
thema haben komisch dass wir von china
immer noch oder china
doch gar nichts versteht schon leibnitz
sagt wir haben selbst andere spiele von
den chinesen kann man eigentlich gar
nichts begreift und ich habe immer noch
das gefühl dass wenn es einen ort gibt
der diesen planeten extrem fremd ist
dann ist es wahrscheinlich die
chinesische
das gedankenexperiment jahren auf
chinesischen ende natürlich auch das ja
aber dass das stück erzählt mal was
plant ihr denn für die nächsten
sternstunden möchtest dich philosophie
das holen was machen eine philosophie
des hundes genau das ist mir sehr
wichtig dass wir die tiere reinbringen
und dann hoffe ich noch dass wir es
schaffen ein sehr sehr verehrten großen
französischen schriftstellern die
sendung zu holen
emanuel kharja der wie kein anderer
literatur und philosophische reflexion
verbindet das wäre für mich ein ganz
großes anliegen war das ist ein mensch
und ein geistig sehr schätze
wir haben schon eine zusage von einem
jüngeren französischen schriftsteller
nämlich etwa louis der auch jetzt für
die geld besten stellungen gezählt eine
gitarre genau hat das ganz gut stellung
bezogen hat genau der kommt im februar
und ich möchte eigentlich anke engelke
die große humoristischen kommen und den
einladen im nächsten jahr das ist aber
noch nicht sicher ob das klappen
genau das ist bei dir aus dem april wert
marina abramovic ihr sein da bin ich ein
sehr gespanntes ich werde auch preisen
zeigen und dann schauen wir mal wie das
wirkt und dann freue ich mich im februar
ein gespräch mit einer afghanischen
it-spezialisten die kennt man hier noch
nicht so roja mabhuh eis die die er
setzt sich ein für gleiche
bildungschancen für frauen in
afghanistan und riskiert dafür auch
morddrohungen da bin ich sehr gespannt
und natürlich am fünften februar der
nächste philosophische stammtisch in
basel wenn sie zeit im blut haben nach
hause zu kommen in sutz freue ich mich
sehr
karten für die auszeichnung sind online
erhältlich auf unserer webseite und dann
die großen themen nächstes jahr
vielleicht noch genau an was oder
übernächstes jahr lag sie ist wirklich
fantastisch wenn man sich wirklich gar
nicht vorstellen kann wie ein land das
so eine tiefe demokratische kultur hat
sich in solch eine ausweglose situation
manövrieren kann
das ist wirklich etwas das glaube ich
doch gar nicht richtig verstanden ist
wie es zu solchen irrationalität schüben
kommen konnte ich war ja vor einem jahr
in irland und die nordirland und da
haben wir eigentlich schon
vorausschauend auf dem brett cit gedreht
so in beiden ländern und das war
unglaublich bewegend da wirklich dieser
grenze auch entlang zu marschieren und
die behalte ich es schilder zu sehen so
hart bordell als wir das problem
natürlich auf dieser grünen insel die
man umgeht mit dieser grenze
ob das wieder eine harte grenze wird was
es nicht werden
es ist teil der abmachung aber
nordirland ist ja so ein bisschen das
zünglein an der waage auch in diesem
ganzen verhandlungen ich bin ich auch
sehr gespannt ist allerding und zweiter
großer punkt wird natürlich auch sein
wie sich die präsidentschaft kampf
entwickelt und ob diese ganzen legalen
schwierigkeiten es sich wie ein
spinnennetz über ihn legen so dass er
gar nicht mehr handlungsfähig würde ich
glaube also angloamerikanischen raum ist
einer der uns nächstes jahr sehr stark
beschäftigt habe mir selbst sehr viele
gäste auch jetzt so francis fukuyama zum
beispiel auf sofern das populismus
identitätspolitik wird uns
wahrscheinlich weiterhin gestellt und
champagner natürlich sport haben schon
auch was natürlich auch weitergehende
jetzt leider ist die ganze dekoration
den klimawandel und wenden und zurück
blickt muss man ja auch mal sagen der
sommer 2018 geht ein auf der wärmste
sommer in der messung der geschichte und
das hat schon auch was verrücktes in den
jahresrückblicken die gerade so am
laufen aber ich das gefühl das kommt ja
nicht so oft vor
in meinem kopf ist das extrem präsent
dieser unglaublich schöne sommer der
gleichzeitig immer auch diesen
wermutstropfen mit sich führt was man
weiß
irgendetwas stimmt nicht ganz aber das
war ja das schöne an der sendung mit
steven pinker mit einem psychologen dass
er sagt irgendwie in den medien kommt
immer nur das schlechte weil diese
ereignisse meistens schlecht sind und
die aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen
aber die lange entwicklung die werden
nicht gezeigt und der klimawandel ist
sondern neben negative entwicklung er
betont natürlich vor allem die positiven
entwicklungen die wir irgendwie nicht
präsent haben und meinen die welt gehen
und das vielleicht auch was worauf ihren
bestand schon beachten müssen
philosophen geld nehmen als kritisch als
diejenigen das dunkle und das schlechte
betrachten das passiert sehr viel gutes
auf der welt und man kann auch über das
gute
schön für das sortieren das heißt wenn
pinkafeld dass sie journalisten gerne
auf die dunklen themen gehen hat er
vielleicht recht dass wir das gute gut
und das schöne zu wenig bedenken
aber manchmal wenn man jetzt mit dem
klimawandel noch viel viel extremere
szenarien sich aus denkt denkt ihr zum
beispiel es wäre gut für den planeten
wenn es inzwischen nicht mehr gäbe den
menschen nicht mehr gehen
ich glaube das passiert früh genug jetzt
kosmisch gedacht ich meine das ist doch
eigentlich browns wert wenn wir
aussterben habe ich die dame zuerst
selbstverständlich ist es dort also wir
reden darüber dass der mensch nicht mehr
existiert und schenken champagner ist
ganz offenherzig freund es kann noch
viel gutes passieren ich möchte die frau
die ganze aber irgendwie ist das schwer
zu denken dann auch alle werte ja
wechsel mit den menschen oder eben nicht
so klar kam das universum wertvoll sein
oder den menschen wahrscheinlich schon
also solange sie wissen doch an auf die
vorsätze vorsätzen offen seien viele
dinge die passieren ja das wäre ein
vorwärts und sie haben keine zeit die
stunde ist nämlich vorbei genau ich
möchte euch ganz herzlich danken war
sehr schön mit euch zum ersten mal im
studio zu sein gemeinsam auch in zu
hause möchten wir von ganzem herzen
danke sagen dafür dass sie uns so treu
begleiten und mit uns und unseren gästen
mitdenken und mitdiskutieren
über die großen fragen unserer zeit wir
haben soeben einer den blick in die
zukunft gewagt und das tut auf andere
weise auch die astrologie die am 6
januar thema ist in der sternstunde
religion moderiert übrigens von unserer
neuen kollegin olivia berlin
und sie ist bereits am ersten januar auf
sendung dann geht es um den zürcher
reformator zwingli und jetzt gleich
sehen sie den film closer to court eine
reise nach pakistan in die welt der
islamischen mystik mit ihrem
zauberhaften gesehen
bleiben sie also dran und alles gute im
neuen jahr so und jetzt dürfen wir
endlich anstoßen
schluss
[Musik]